マネジメントの質がまだ上司もまだまだ
未熟だってことだ。コンピテンモデルって
言うんだけど、実際自社で活躍してる人の
共通校てのあるじゃん。そういう共通校を
しっかり明確にして、ま、究極
言ってしまうと
経営者の愛だと青木サの人生学100回
聞いたら豊かになる話。今回はですね、
あの、新卒が3年でやめてしまう職場の
共通点ということで、あの、実際こう、ま
、約3割が3年以内に、ま、離職をすると
新卒側から見た離職理由のトップ3って、
ま、業務内容が希望とミスマッチしてたと
か、ま、体遇とか福利合成に対する不満と
かキャギャリア形成が望めないみたいな
あの、離職の理由あったりするんです
けれども新卒が3
年でやめてしまう職場の共通点。青木社長の見解を教えていただけますでしょうか?ま、今のさに新卒が求めているもの岡口君が言ったいくつかのポイントあるじゃん。それが得られないかだろ。非常に明解だよね。てことは経営者がそのことを与えられる努力が足りないってことでしょ。
[音楽]
ずっと遡ってみると、ま、正直ね、
やっぱりその採用ミスっていうのもあると
思うんですよ。1つはね、安易にね、基準
を下げて人手が足りないからと言って中途
半端に妥協して採用すると採用した後問題
が起こるよね。うちみたいに相当基準高く
採用プロセス7段階ぐらい前置いてね、
それで、え、役員面談まで来るぐらいやっ
ても採用ミスってのあるわけですよ。で、
採用ミスって何かって言うと、一言で言え
ば、ま、うちの仕事で言うと別に教育じゃ
なくてもいいやって。教育のビジネスで
なくてもいいや。いや、俺本当にやり
たかったことは教育じゃないんじゃないか
なと。俺本当にやりたかったことって人材
教育コンサルティングじゃないんじゃない
のと。俺本当にやりたかったことは別に
選択を世の中に広めることじゃなくても
いいんじゃないか。お客様に対して研修の
ね、受行を進めたりこう相談に乗ってる
よりももっと手っ取り早くコミッションで
稼げる仕事いくらでもあるよなって。不
動産会社に行ったまるまる君コミッション
でこんなに稼いでるじゃないか。これ採用
ミスなんですよ。こういう人材採用しちゃ
ダメなんだ、本当は。ところがやっぱり
採用しちゃうんだよというのはわかんない
もん。入社まではみんないいこと言うから
。どうしたら目標達成するか。目標達成
って採用を勝ち取ることですから。内定を
勝ち取る。まず新卒の子からするとゴール
じゃん。相手を勝ち取るぞ。戦略考えるよ
ね。そうすると理念研究したりビジョン
考えたり相手が研究し尽くして望んでる
ことを面接は言うからね。で、私はどう
いう風にして採用に焦点当ててきたかて
いうと行動観察です。言葉じゃないと巨と
いう字あるじゃん。今という字の横に
口描くと嘘なるんだよ。だから口で今日
語ることを嘘だと私よく言うんだけど結局
ねずっとやりますとかもうこの仕事が私の
障害をかけれる仕事ですとか嘘だったんだ
よ。やっぱ色々変わるわけよ。でもねそれ
はしょうがないんだよ。そういうもんなん
だよ。人間ってのは。いや本当になんかね
こと言うようじゃない。言ってるようだ
けれども実際それを踏まえてそれでも自分
はやっぱり理想を掲げながら自分の求める
人材像を明確にしてじゃその人材像って
どうしたら見えるかって言うと今現在活躍
してる人のコンピテンCモデルって言うん
だけど実際自社で活躍してる人の共通校
ってのあるじゃん。そういう共通行を
しっかり明確にしてそういう支出を持っ
てる人を採用するわけだよ。それでも
外れるっていうことはあるんだよ。ま、
それはそれででもチャレンジし続ける。
そして長い間には適正能力がある人間が
残りやめる人間は社会に返してあげたと。
そう考えてでどっかで活躍してればいい
わけよ。なんかね、自分のところだけに
もう全部いて自分のところで成功しない
やつは歯者だみたいに考えない方がいい。
もう私はね、社会に返すってもうそれ
ぐらいの気持ちで今捉えてます。ま、うち
の場合はどうだろうな。毎年うん。5%
から7%ぐらい離職率。うん。だ、大体
年間、ま、大体78人じゃないのかな、
平均でね。多分ま、正直やめるたら損んだ
なと思うよ。初人休33万円だからね、
うちこんな会社ね、世の中そんなにないよ
。平均年収655万だから。いや、本当に
。でもやめるやつはやめるんだよ。
なぜ?これね、すごく大事なポイントなの
。今のね、質問にじゃあちょっと直接的な
答になっていくけど、まずね、
マネジメントの質がまだ上司もまだまだ
未熟だってことな。負荷をかけすぎたり、
優秀な人間に複数の仕事、いろんな案件が
集まってきて、で、その子もいい子だから
なんとか期待に答えようと思って背負い
すぎてパンパンになって仕事が嫌いになっ
ちゃう。感が出るほど働きすぎたとか。だ
、その働きすぎってダメなのよ。そこを
マネージャーが優秀だとブレーキ踏むんだ
よね。ブレーキ踏むとクラッシュ起こさ
なくて済むわけじゃん。自動車レースで
言うと。だクラッシュ起きた現象だけ見る
とあいつは弱かったなとか、あいつはダメ
だったんだって言ってるケースがあるんだ
けどそうじゃないよと。だ普通世間一般の
会社ってつったらまずマネジメントがボス
型ですよ。批判する、責める、文句を言う
、神々言う、脅す、罰ツ与える、目先の帯
で釣る。これをやる職場はまず離職が耐え
ない。それに対して継長する、支援する、
励ます。需要する、信頼する、尊重する、
意見の違いについて常に交渉する。ま、
これはね、是非あのうちの取締まり役のね
、橋本拓也が書いた部下を持ったらは最初
に読む本っていうね、この本読んで
いただきた。これベストセラーでその本
読んでもらうと分かるんだけど、やっぱ人
は自分の思い通りには動かせないんですよ
。相手の立場に立って相手の望みを叶える
ことを自分の望みとしなければいけないの
で相手の望みの中に会社や仕事の内容や
上司のその信頼関係で上司の期待に答え
たいとかそれから自分のライフデザインの
中で確実に自分は見通しを持って心昇格し
ていけるようなそのラインを引いてあげる
ことだとかそういうことをしっかりと時間
取るってことだよね。忙しすぎると時間
取れなくなっちゃうんですよ。だちゃんと
時間を取って真味になって相談に乗って
あげると、ま、リテンショて言うんだけど
定着率は良くなるとそんな風に思います。
だからま、本当に今実は売り手と買い手
っていう言葉があるんだけど働く人の方が
強いよね。正直うん、企業側が弱くなっ
てると思います。なぜならあの人手不足な
んでやめてもどこでも働けるんですよ。だ
、やっぱマネジメントの質、この質を
クオリティ、常質というものを本当に研究
して、やっぱりその内発的同期付けが
起きるような職場、環境、人事制度、
仕事の内容、マネジメントの質をしっかり
と整えていくことが、ま、大切なポイント
じゃないかなと私は考えてます。
[音楽]
基本的には
、ま、究極言ってしまうと
経営者の愛だと思い
採用した人間を採用責任を持とうと真剣に
選んでいただいた以上はこの会社で
ちゃんと自己実現していけるように良い
会社にしようと思っていたら歩みよりも
あるだだろうし、マネジメントの質も
変えるだろうし、逆に上司が謝ると思い
ます。ごめんと
もっと時間を咲いてあげればよかったね。
ごめんね。これ謝るような
上司がいる会社は、あ、すいません。私の
勘違いでした。もう1回頑張りますって
言ったらいい。でも謝れないような会社
ってどっか人を金儲けマシンみたいに思っ
てんだよ、正直。だから名前どころか番号
で覚えてるみたいな、もしくはもう最悪の
会社なんて
社員のことパーツって呼んだ社長がいた
からね。パーツを変えるてふざけろってな
話でしょ。そういう会社はもうダメだよね
。だからやっぱり人を人として人を大切に
する会社、そういう会社を目指していけば
人がやめない会社になるんじゃないかなと
いうのが私の考え方ですね。なんか気づい
たこと、感じたことあればコメント欄にお
願いします。是非ね、え、チャンネル登録
、まだの方はチャンネル登録もお願いし
ます。また次回のYouTubeで会い
ましょう。よろしくお願いします。
ありがとうございます。
あの、ちなみにこう、今、ま、定着率を逆
にこう高めていくためにっていう目線で
メッセージしていただいたんですけれども
、あの、やめていく新卒側の立場になった
時になんかそのよくこう言われるのは、
まあ3年は我慢しなさい言葉もよくあると
思うんですね。
なんか職場が合わないなと思ったらなんか
年は我慢しておくべきなのかみたいなところに対して青木社長の考えってありますか?まずね、本質的長期的客観的な視点に立って判断しなきゃいけないんですよ。だまずその会社が入って見てね外からすごくいいこと言われて入ったと。
入ったら人を大切にしてる会社かどうか、
人を粗末にしてる会社かどうか
それはやっぱりうん。マネジメントの質で
分かりますよね。ま、さっき言ったような
外的コントロール心理学というようなもの
がもうはびこっている。灰皿が飛ぶような
職場とかもう不動産業界でも昔は市内が
マネージャーの机の後ろに置いてあって
バーンとかもう脅しとかもうそうやって靴
を与えるマネジメントで予算達成させると
かね。それからもう亡くなった会社って
いうかもうおかしくなった会社の中でね
びっくりモーターターってあったじゃんね
。これ正式な写名言わないけど。あ、
びっくりしたよ、俺。木ーカすとかさ。
そうでしょ。そんな会社だと思ったら
さっさとやめた方がいいよ。そんな、ま、
1ヶ月でもやめた方がいいと思うよ、俺。
いや、1ヶ月はちょっと大げさか。ま、
長くてどうなの?反社会的な会社だったら
、ま、一応最悪の会社の勉強っていうこと
で、どんなに長くても1年じゃないの?
なぜならそんな会社で学ぶべきものはない
よ。だ、ま、ある意味で良い経験を積んだ
とはなるよね。だから変な人と交際し
ちゃったと。すごいDV受けたと。それね
、どんなに忍耐しててもね、
相手を変えようとしない方がいい。自分は
離れた方が健全だと思います。いや、これ
すごく大事な。あのね。うん。
このね、人生成功の鍵はね、正しい選択
です。
だからカウンセリング的に言うと離れ
るっていうことです。
ただただ死だよ。客観的に見なきゃだめな
ん。本質的に見なきゃだめ。長期的に見
なきゃだめな。今ね、例えばだよ。
アチブメントだって昔はマンション
オフィスだったんだ。社員5名賞金
500万で吹けば飛ぶような会社ですよ。
でも今ねおかげ様でこういう
アチューメントになりました。軽団連にも
入りねもう当初の銀用にもなった。でも昔
はマンションオフスじゃん。でもうちは
将来性があったんだよ。っていうことは
分かりやすい話が私が高いしを持って
たってことだよ。だから経営者、
あのね、あのよくね、教会でもね、
なんだろう。そこの教会のスタッフを見て
教会に通わなくなっちゃう信者さんって
いるのよ。でも神様見なきゃいけないのに
そこのスタッフを見ちゃうんだよね。
これでもね、しょうがないんだよ。なぜ
なら人を見てね、この教会で教えてること
は本物かどうかって見ちゃう。そういう
傾向がある。でも本当に成功したいと思っ
たらその会社のトップを見る。だ、トップ
がどこ目指してるかを見る。理念を見る。
ビジョンを見る。言ってることとやってる
ことを見る。そのギャップがないかどうか
を見る。そして去年よりも今年確実に良く
なってるか事実を見る車種を見る。つまり
長期的、客観的本的に見てユートピアは
ないので
自分がユートピアにしていくでアチュー
メントっていう会社は社員にあなたの給料
は誰が決めてるって聞いたらうちの社員は
全員240人例外なく私の給料は私の働き
方が決めてますって答えるんだ。でも世間
一般の会社ってあなたの給料は誰が決めて
るてたら私の給料は会社が決めてます。
もしくは社長が決めてます。もしくは人事
が決めてますって言うじゃん。
ここ大事なポイントなんです。私の給料は
私の働き方が決めてますと言えるような
企業文化の会社は素晴らしい会社だと思い
ます。うん。ま、社会性があって、そして
やっぱり心志しがあって、本当に人のため
に良い理念を持ってやってる会社なら規模
関係なく将来性があるのでとまった方が
いいと。どんなに規模が大きくても人を
傷つけたりね、例えば産業廃棄物を不法
登記したり、反社会的なことを平気でやっ
ていたり、そういう会社はさっさと離れた
方がいい。それが1つの判断基準なんじゃ
ないのかなと私は思います。